Hello my name is Jonathan Worth and as
well as being freelance photographer I'm
also a researcher at Newcastle
University's Open Lab in the UK.
The interviews you're about to hear are part
of a series that, along with the web platform
and connected classes, seek to
create a space for
critical engagement with visual storytelling.
The relationship between the photographer, the subject and the audience
(the three stakeholders in every photograph)
are central to the Talking Pictures
interviews, but there are occasions when
those stakeholders might not be three
different people.
In the case of the self-portrait, the photographer and the subject to the same person.
In the case of the selfie that isn't shared or
published, the photographer, the subject
and the audience are one and the same.
The theme for this session is "Interpretation" and the people who have
agreed to help us think about that are
the Scottish photographer Graham Macindoe and the U.S. journalist Susan Stellan.
For reasons that will become
clear
Graham chose not to share his
self-portraits for over ten years
and many of the images from this series
and from this time in his life,
he's still not chosen to publish.
Both him and Susan reflect on the ethical implications
of representing other people, the duty of care for the vulnerable
and they consider how the
effect and impact of an image might be
felt long after it was made, and long
after the subject
may have moved on with their life.
I first met Graham in New York in 1998 he helped me
find a place to live and help me find places to work.
He was intense. He was brash with his
thick Scottish accent that he refused to
let go of, and he was funny.
He was generous, he was very caring of his
friends, and he was successful as well.
He was shooting huge jobs. He was travelling all over the world.
He someone who was constantly in motion,
both figuratively and literally.
He was also a compulsive collector both of the ephemeral and of images.
Everything had a story attached to it and everything was super tasteful.
To this day the photographs of that period of my life, that hang in my home, were made by Graham.
We moved away from New York at the end
of 2001 and towards the end it had
become harder and harder to keep up with
him.
By 2005 it was impossible and it remains a regret that we lost touch.
Back in the UK news of Graham now was
coming second and third-hand. I learned
that he he'd got divorced.
I'd learned that he wasn't working anymore.
I learned that there'd been a newspaper report of an explosion at his house,
that he'd been arrested, and that finally he was in prison.
As you listen to this interview you'll hear from Graham the photographer,
Graham the subject and
Graham the publisher.
You'll hear how even at his lowest ebb he was still considering the ethical implications of
making other people's images, and how he
and Susan chose to share the work,
taking into consideration how the contexts
would affect how the various audiences
would interpret it and be affected.
And so it's fitting that Susan has the last word,
not only on this story, but also on
this interview itself.
There are also links to related bodies of work that, along with this material, should inform
a critical discourse about vulnerability,
responsibility and how we choose to
represent issues and so frame the conversations around them.
[Graham] My name's Graham Macindoe and I'm speaking to you guys from Brooklyn, New York in my
living room, and you might hear a few
cars going by because  I'm pretty close to the expressway.
I grew up in Scotland between
Edinburgh and Glasgow and you know,
I spent a lot of my youth being into music
and specifically punk music in the late
70's and through the 80's and I went
to art school in Edinburgh where I
actually studied painting and then to
London where  I went to the Royal College which
was quite a jump for me because I hadn't
studied photography at all.
I'd studied painting but I'd always taken photographs and somehow I managed to get into the Royal College
which was still pretty amazing to me, because it was very prestigious at the time.
And then after two years at the Royal College where I met my then-girlfriend
and had my son Liam. I moved to New York to follow a career in photography.
When I first moved to New York I wasn't
sure what I was going to do in photography.
I knew I wanted to work within the field of photography, I fallen in love with it
and was pretty passionate about it,
but the five years I spent working in galleries. But because I was always taking pictures,
I eventually moved on into working commercially as a photographer.
Before I knew it I was photographing for a lot of magazines, working on commercial ad campaigns,
getting flown all over the world to do
annual reports and photographing
Gary Oldman, I photographed Michael
Jackson. I got sent a film sets so I was
photographing, you know, for Nike and ESPN  so the trajectory at that point was
really, really quick for me. It wasn't I really envisaged for myself -
working at that level as a commercial photographer.
People would do stuff for you and so it was very foreign to me. I was always really surprised when people
threw money at you and then give you more money to buy your breakfast and your lunch and a
cup of coffee and someone to  help you and  a taxi and all that sort of stuff.
That world which really surprising to me. Very, very surprising to me. Even I thought that
I was it was too much money sometimes and I was getting paid it.
But of course not all photography is really well  paid, you know? I mean photojournalism and editorial
I think is... you can make a living and it's
a good living but yet you're not getting
paid what you're getting paid for
shooting advertising campaigns and
that's where the real money comes in.
It was interesting to be, you know, in a position
where people would call you up and say:
"Hey, you available next week? We would
like to send you to L.A. to photograph Randy Newman.
We're doing an article on him,  but I've often
found that its the people that you get
sent that have an interesting
story about them, that are not on that
celebrity band-waggon, that
are more inclined to give you more time and
more inclined to reveal things about themselves.
Even if you don't agree with it. I've photographed some people that
politically, I might not agree with, or you
know, or some of their stances, I'm just like...
Wow! But they  always have something interesting about them that reveals something to me about how other people live their lives.
Those jobs are more fulfilling for me.
I enjoyed that sort of,  you know,  meeting these people who are not in the public eye
or they might be doing something that's slightly interesting and someone's picked up on it
and saw some magazines doing a feature on it.
I started working as a photographer because
I was someone who was always
taking pictures. I took portraits of friends,
I photographed landscapes, I did.. I photographed everything that was going on around me you know,
because I really loved photography.
I still take pictures now.
I've always taken pictures. I mean I just..
.. sometimes I think it's are almost like an affliction.
I encourage all my students to keep
sketchbooks and notebooks you know,
I don't like them to be taking out and
writing notes on their phones.
I like them to be carrying sketchbooks you know,
I tell them and I send them on the first day
in class at the beginning of semester,
go to the store it's just round the corner,
spend five bucks, buy a sketchbook and
just write your ideas and then scribble
ideas and if you find a piece of paper
or a picture on the street or a Polaroid
or whatever it is, stick it in there. When
you look back through it will be much
more meaningful than a note on your
iPhone that you can delete accidentally
and doesn't have any real aesthetic
value. I still do it but I try to get
my students to do it  a lot, you know.
People, especially now, people are very
interested in seeing what your vision is
and what you can bring to the table
as opposed to what you've brought to the
table for other people.
So I've had several years of working as a really successful commercial photographer,
working editorially, working for
advertising agencies, flying all around the world.
Being lucky enough to meet
celebrities and you know, sort of the dream
world of a photographer to be perfectly
honest with you.
But er.. . during that period
I'd started drinking too much, I'd started
dabbling with drugs and..
it just took me off at a tangent that I never, ever really expected in my life you know.
I slowly but surely and very insidiously,
the drugs kicked in and I became a very,
very bad heroin and crack cocaine addict.
Susan:
I first met Graham Macindoe in 2002 when we were both part of the same Summer house
out in Montauk at the end of Long Island, near New York.
At the time he was
working as a commercial photographer
There were a lot of us who kind of
came and went to that house over the
course of the summer and I really just
knew him as someone who partied a bit
and drink, I would say, more than the
average person.
At the time he had a girlfriend
and we sort of lost touch over that, after that Summer.
Then I reached out to him in 2005, when I needed an author photo taken for a travel book I'd written,
and went over to get my picture taken,
at that point Graham wasn't in that relationship anymore, I wasn't in a relationship,
and by the end of that very long photoshoot in that afternoon
the next day he asked me out on a date.
I was living on the Upper West Side,
he was living in Brooklyn and in New York we joked
that that's sort of a long-distance relationship.
You know we really only saw each other on weekend so
it took a while for me to realise that
there was something..
a little bit off about him.
We tend to see and experience
addiction as viewers at the extreme end of the spectrum
you know we don't really have a popular conception of the "functional addict".
So, for me, the idea that Graham could be functional as a photographer
and a guy that I would be interested in dating..
at first people just would ask well how could you not have known
it wasn't obvious to me and
you know we have pictures from a trip we
took to Hawaii
and my Mom when she saw this photos,
she said "oh he looks so wholesome".
Unbeknownst to me or really anyone else he was using heroin at the time.
I was still working for many years during that time
so I thought,  I'm still working, I'm making money I'm not that bad you know,
this is just a period I'm going through but, you know,
as you get more and more in to drugs
your awareness of where you are and what's going on with you fitters-away and..
by the time I.. sort of realised.. and tried to do anything about it, I was really deep in.
I eventually found out that Graham was using drugs when I found him
sitting on the couch in his house at the crack pipe.
For a variety of reasons I didn't end up breaking up with him right then
so I sort of stuck around for a while
you know, and then until it became apparent that he really just
wasn't getting the help and I thought, me
being/continuing in a relationship
was actually hurting things more than was
helping.
And think I had this, feeling that you know
we all have that, sort of tough love
if I just walk away..  you know, that's going to motivate him to quit
I've always taken pictures and even in the depths of my addiction, where I didn't work
commercially for years, and my whole
life was unraveling and
I'd isolated myself from everyone that I knew
and I was on a very, very slippery, dark downhill path I was still taking pictures
but it wasn't only the pictures that I was taking that were, sort of, from that period
I collected all the (being a compulsive collector of things in my whole life),
and so I.. I was intrigued by the design of the heroin baggies that I was buying around New York City
I didn't see it as collecting at a time, I just kept them because I was intrigued by them, I loved the designs,
I loved the quirky little pictures with
guns and cartoon characters and you know,
statements on them that were just
totally over the top sometimes.
so I'd be sticking them in books or little boxes and stuff like that and also just other
things that were going on around me you
know I was writing in scrapbooks,
you know, I was keeping letters I was keeping.. I got arrested a number of times,
I kept the arrest warrants. I kept all that sort of stuff. Court appearances, rehab papers, stuck them in boxes.
I was surprised when I came through all that sort of stuff and got myself clean
and a couple of different friends of mine had stuck stuff in storage
or kept things in their houses for me and I started pulling that stuff together
I started finding all this stuff
again. I started finding the heroin baggies
and the notebooks and the
Polaroids and the undeveloped rolls of
35mm film and 120 film and, and then I
started finding all these cards
hundreds and hundreds of pictures I had taken during those years over maybe
six or seven years, and not really.. knowing I was doing it, and sometimes looking on
sometimes not looking at them and sometimes losing the cards
and sometimes having the cameras stolen by other junkies.
I didn't feel I had the right to show the pictures of the other people that I'd photographed
because the consent thing with addicts is very, very difficult
you'll say and do a lot of things as an addict ..
and say everything's okay then
the reality of day when you're clean you
just go "My God I would never do or say that"
so I've decided to make it all
about me.
[Susan] Another point in the code of ethics is "Give special consideration to
vulnerable subjects"
and that's something that Graham has addressed in explaining why he decided not to photograph other addicts
is this issue of consent.
You know, we recognise now that someone
who is addicted to drugs and has a
serious problem, you know,
they have difficulties with decision-making and making rational choices. So, to say that
this person can consent to having their
picture taken and then published I think
is a bit problematic because, you know, we
recognise that you know,
they aren't really making decisions that are
informed by rational choices
and I think that is something that we really need to think about because
that person might get clean and then later regret that their images out in the world
showing them at their worst moment and
they can't take it back.
[Graham] I had started taking photographs of the people around me in their environment
and sometimes I've ended up in the pictures and then
it just felt more pertinent for me to photograph myself because I was living that life and
I shouldn't really be pointing the camera at other people I felt I should be pointed it at myself.
[Susan] So fast forward a few years and I had
lost touch with him at that point
he had really gone downhill.
We kept in touch occasionally via email but then,
he just disappeared off the radar, and I started reaching out to a couple other people who had known him.
Just sort of under the assumption that maybe he'd overdosed
because his phone had been turned off. The website he used to promote his photography was offline.
[Graham] I mean I spent close to a decade of my life juggling too much drinking dabbling with drugs
turning, into a serious addiction,  and
everything that went along with that.
And I kept telling myself that I could get clean on my own.
I kept thinking it was something I could do. Just to willpower and strength,
and it's just like, I just need
to buckle down and do it, but you know,
I was totally incapable.
Strangely enough the most devastating thing for me at that time
was a finally been arrested and sentenced to six months in Rikers Island,
which is a prison on an island on the outskirts of New York City
and I think it's one of the biggest penal colonies in the world,
which totally blew me away
because
it was somewhere I never, ever thought I would end up in.
So I "cold-turkeyed" in a cell in Rikers Island, which was a really, really painful thing you know?
The physicality of it.
And then once you get that out of your system a little bit, the readjusting in your body to being clean
and then psychologically the..
you know, realisation of where the last
several years of your life have been, are
really crushing you know?
I mean it was a really, really tough time for me but I also gave me that moment of clarity,
as they call it,  where I sort of could look back and say "Wow!", I just put myself through this
and my friends through this, and my family
through this, and thinking of the collateral
damage to my Mom and my Dad and my
friends and my son and everyone was really big.
[Susan] By the time I tracked him
down he was actually due to be released from Rikers and
rather than getting released, he ended up in Homeland Security custody
and was very quickly moved to detention centres in, first in downtown Manhattan,
and then in New Jersey, and then Pennsylvania.
So I managed to get someone at the prison
where he was being held in Pennsylvania
to give him my phone number and that's
when we reconnected.
[Graham] I was in a County Jail in Pennsylvania that had an immigration wing and I found out they had a
24/7 cognitive behavioural therapy
program in there for four months
and that's, that's how I got clean
essentially, was in a prison rehabilitation program.
And it set the groundwork for me to, when I got out,  to build on that
and I've been clean ever since which is seven and half years, or something like that.
[Susan] We talked on the phone, we exchanged these
really intense letters, and you know by
the time his final hearing was coming up,
it was as lawyer who actually asked if I
would be okay with Graham coming to stay
with me for a while if he got released?
So all of a sudden he was on a bus
getting out at
the Port Authority Terminal near Times
Square in New York and that was the
first time we saw each other when we
were not separated by Plexiglas.
That was the first time I seen him in almost two years so, he came to stay with me and
he's still here! Could never get rid of
him [laughs] we actually just got married in May of 2017
But when he was released, maybe not nine months clean but also
having spent nine months incarcerated, so
he wasn't Graham the photographer.
I think he didn't know who he was and that was the process of rebuilding, you know not
just from that time away from everything,
but also almost a decade of addiction.
So, it was a long process, I mean he, at first
he didn't have any interest in picking up a camera
he would go to a grocery store and just stand in the aisles kind of mystified by
the amount of choice that you had because all that's taken away when you're incarcerated.
You know, he didn't have any interest in having a phone.
He didn't have any interest in a computer. You know, it took a long time for Graham to
you know feel pleasure again from the things that
I feel pleasure from. You know, whether it's a great meal, or sex, or running, or
photography, you know, and that's because
your brain changes from addiction you
know, particularly with dopamine's and
you know,
I don't think people get prepared for how long that's going to take.
[Graham] So now that I've been clean for a bit and I've started pulling together my life
and have rediscovered all this.. sort of
ephemera and stuff,
the photographs, the baggies, the notebooks, the Polaroids all that sort of stuff from the
years of addiction, I'd spent a lot of time
looking through them and, it was somewhat
upsetting for me and sort of.. looking at
these because even though I was clean
now and I was happy I was clean and I was
not 100% comfortable talking to people
about what I've been through because I
was still in that place that's sort of.. as an
addict your shame-based, because it's not
like some that you boast about is being
a heroine addict, or a crack addict. Its something that you're pretty ashamed of know?
So, its a difficult thing to reveal
to people and some people.. a lot of people
knew about it, some people didn't, and I
would bump into people who would say
"Oh, where have you been the last few years? I haven't heard from you in ages, what's been going on?"
and the last thing you want to say is
"Oh, hey! It's good to see you I've been a heroin addict I was locked up in prison"
[Susan]  The first time I saw them I mean it was just gut-wrenching
and it was it was so devastating
but also at the same time compelling, because it showed me what Graham had been up to
in these rooms and stairwells and places
that I'd never seen and I actually wrote
about it in a journal at the time where
I kind of described that attraction and
this voyeurism to wanting to know about
this part of his life he'd kept hidden,
but then also how sad it was because
what Graham chose to show was
so much loneliness and in all the photos you know, by and large, he's by himself
and just what his life had been reduced to.
[Graham] It took a lot of time looking at them
because some of the pictures were really,
really, really disturbing and some of the
really disturbing ones I haven't put out
there because it's too rough on my
family and my wife and myself even, for
people to see certain images.
They're just too tough, you know?
They show me in a light I just don't want to share .
[Susan] When he did start showing them to people there were really a range of reactions.
One friend of ours just, you know, ran crying from the room when she first saw them.
[Graham] It was hard looking at it, and it was hard working out at who the audience would be.
Why would I want to show it?
Who would this resonate with?
And what would be their takeaway?
It was like I took these pictures of myself and...
this is what I went through and I
want you to understand people end up in
this situation and what they go through, and..
that they can recover as well.
It's really important to me the, you know,
the takeaway for this is that
you can go through this stuff and you can recover.
I think that's missing from a lot of addiction photo essays and stuff like that.
People are perfectly happy to photograph the addicts,
the junkies, the torn down buildings, or
the desolate isolated places and they're
always.. a lot of the times seeing victims and they always never seem to recover and
never seems to be an end story to it apart from, look at these addicts.
So I wanted to show, "look at this addict" coming from me as the recovered addict.
[Susan] When Graham first started talking about or proposing that he might show these images
to some photo editors, or think about publishing them, or exhibiting them,
my first reaction was that that was a
really scary thought, you know,
not negative, that he shouldn't do it, but
just concern about how these images
would be interpreted. So one of the
things that I suggested is that if he
was going to publish these images that
he include text accompanying the images,
that he tell his story so that he could, to some degree, shape how people reacted to them.
[Graham] My response from magazines was immediate. I sent emails to a couple of
picture editors. It was a couple of embedded pictures and was then like half an hour,
which is unknown for picture editors,
they were back at me saying
"Oh we love these. Can you bring them in? Can you show us more? We're really interested in publishing them".
We eventually decided to publish them was text by Susan, which was an interview basically
in New York magazine and it got so much feedback but
because we mulled over it for so long, it
was a really well-done piece and
it really resonated and I was really happy with it and the feedback from the people that saw it
(the audience) was amazing.
[Susan] So after the article it first
appeared in New York Magazine in print
and obviously there was an accompanying
piece online that did have the
photography and the text and some audio,
we literally sat looking at the computer
waiting for the comments to start scrolling in.
There was a person who thought that Graham had faked this whole thing
in order to get published and you know potentially get an exhibit,
and that really sparked this thread
about whether or not someone who was a
heroin addict really would have the capacity to set a self timer and take pictures of himself?
and I think that gets back to this idea that
we don't really understand or believe in the
concept of someone who can be somewhat functional
or in some cases very functional while using drugs
but there are myriad stories of people who, you know, have held down careers as doctors,
surgeons, lawyers, actors, professors and
then it comes out that you know they had
a serious addiction but yet I think sometimes
because we don't see that depicted in visual imagery we just.. we can't wrap our heads around it.
So in a lot of the Guardian comments there was just this skepticism
"Was he really a heroin addict? Was he really using?"
[Graham] From there it got picked up by Al-Jazeera, The Huffington Post and
that led me to the Scottish National Portrait Gallery
where the curator there approached me and says..
"Listen I've never seen anything like this before,
can you bring these to me and let me see these pictures? These are amazing".
So I went across and met with her and I took maybe..
I made a whole bunch of 8 by 10 prints, maybe about 80 or 90.
We looked through them. I left them with her.
I came back 3 months later, we whittled it down to like 50.
I came back 3 months later we whittled it down to like 25
images that were really powerful and succinct,
and we submitted them to the board of the
Scottish National Portrait Gallery
to see if we could get an acquisition.
To my surprise, I woke up one morning
checked my email and there was an email
from Annie Lydon who's the curator saying
"You'll never believe it.
They decided to acquire all 25 images for the national collection" -
which was mind-boggling to me.
To think back to taking these pictures in these dark places, in these isolated painful times that
you know, the whole.. all through the boards and committees of the National Portrait Gallery
(which is a very traditional body
of people) found this body of work so
compelling and powerful that they would acquire it for their national collection
which was a real.. it was really great for me.
[Susan] It was really a catalyst to these conversations that
I think people were really anxious and interested in having.
So, the series of images became sort of a
gateway to these conversations about
not just addiction but, how do you get clean?
You know, what is that like? What is that Process?
What did you do, what helped you?
Not that Graham's route to recovery is something that is going to work for everybody,
but I think the more we talk about it
the more we can kind of learn about what works in different circumstances.
One of the reasons that
we're we mostly see images of addiction
and addiction sort of at the far end of
the spectrum
is just the shame and the stigma that surrounds substance use disorder.
The imagery is always about the person who's really lost everything.
They're really down and out that's something that's also missing you know from the media
and kind of popular representations of addiction is that recovery piece of it.
Because you know it's maybe not as interesting visually..
Graham keeps asking, "How do you depict recovery?"
"What do you show about that?"
Where, with addiction, I think there is that
voyeurism factor it's something that
people largely haven't seen, although I would argue that maybe,
at this point we have seen a lot of
images of needles going into veins, or
people passed out, or you know, crack
pipes, or drugs kind of close up, and
I think where we're at now is kind of
trying to wrap our heads around
"What is that project or story that you can tell about how people get clean and sober?"
Some people recover without doing you
know, a rehab, or without going to AA.
Other people really rely on those peer
supports. So, I think you know,
finding a way to capture those stories and capture that process is something that we're both really interested in right now.
[Graham] I think it's the most important thing I've I've really done, is put this body work out there
and engage with people and.. you know, as
someone who's been the addict and the recovered person
and revealing that part in my life and
trying to take away some of that shame and trying to take away some of that negativity
that surrounds addiction and giving people that option that,
"You know what? You can go that dark and that deep and end up the places I've been
and still pull yourself out of that and find recovery
and rebuild your life again, and it's not easy.
There was times where it were really, really, really tough.
But you know what?
Being clean is 8 million times better than being a heroin addict. That's for sure.
I mean, it's been a crazy journey,
and a long journey, and a tough journey
for some of the friends who've seen me go
through that (yourself included), but ..
at least I came away from it with something that can help change other people's minds
and bring light to what people can go through and that's been really, really important for me.
[Jonathan] Yeah.   Hah.
[Graham] Was that alright?
[Jonathan] Yeah. Yeah. You got me.
[Graham] Aye alright, sorry.
[Jonathan] Is there anything else you wanted to say?
[Graham] Nah, I think that's about it.
[Susan] So now that you've heard my story and Graham's  story and listened to, you know,
these interviews I kind of challenge you
to think about what we've talked about
and how much of the focus has been on
addiction and the process of, you know,
going from being a successful photographer, to someone who was..  had lost everything
and ended up in a prison cell. Versus the time spent on, you know,
talking about and addressing Graham's
recovery and the treatment he got and
you know, how that worked. Because I think we all have to step back and see how
we're representing this issue and sort
of challenge ourselves to think about it
in different ways and so challenge some of the stereotypes we have about,
"What does addiction look like?"
Is it just the photographs that we see of people like Graham who are slumped over with a needle in their arm?
And when we talk about it why are we
drawn to that imagery more than to
images of people sitting in circles or interviews of people talking about what they had to overcome,
the peer support they got, you know, and some... that is in some sense it's harder to photograph
it's harder to get access but
that's part of the process that we need to be seeing and talking about and thinking about
because that's really key to figuring out what works to help people who are struggling with addiction